i do want to mention one guy ray leota
who is in one of the greatest if not
greatest movies there's this
long-standing debate
for movie fans
is it goodfellas or is it the godfather
that's the better movie goodfellas such
a good movie great movie martin scorsese
just said in an interview he regrets
never having worked with ray liotta
again they had some plans but uh he did
a bunch of movies something wild field
of dreams which he was in great movies
but uh amazing in that when he played
henry hill
and goodfellas that was the best the
real henry hill was arrested on drug
charges became an fbi informant who
testified against the mafia and in 2001
ray was on our show and he told me how
he had to really fight for the role of
henry i chased down goodfellas too
really yeah i had an audition with marty
and then it didn't uh
he was auditioning other people and i
saw him in venice at the venice film
festival and i just chased them down
there i still get scared when i see you
i still think you're like crazy like uh
henry hill you know what i mean wasn't
he in just last week yeah henry was in
when the real henry laughs you got that
laughed down to his science i did yeah
you really did because henry does you
know that is henry's laugh yeah i don't
know that's he's using mine
one of the most famous scenes in
goodfellas is when joe pesci threatens
ray liotta for calling him a funny guy
so now i'm coming around you know i
start to come out of it all i see in
front of me this big frick again he says
what do you want to tell me now tough
guy i said
bing what are you doing here i thought
i'd tell you to go [ __ ] your mother
i thought he was gonna [ __ ]
we actually had the real henry hill on
our show a couple of times and we talked
about his unique laugh
look at you
now you see that laugh that's the that's
henry that is ray leona's left man the
same one that's where he got it from he
got it from henry
yeah ray good looking guy too right
robin
uh
a man
you know like when you think of a man he
was a manly man he was 67 years old and
i know to most of you that sounds like
an old puck but for guys like me that
sounds young i i know you'll see you'll
get there